[Music]
made mistakes but mistakes make you
stronger hey guys welcome to the LM
model lifestyle I'm Daniel is my brother
happening hi and this is the second last
video of her body transformation series
where we go from fat to fit in 12 weeks
now we only have four weeks left so
there's been a lot of changes this last
two weeks I had no lost or kilos yeah
and this is a total almost 15 kilos
which is really good now we only have
four weeks left no we've been talking
about this a lot about the healthy
lifestyle right and so no happen to you
got used to this whole healthy lifestyle
and he learned a lot and now we're
moving the power from me to him and he's
gonna just this diet plan and the
workout routine so it's fits in with him
a little bit better according to
everything that he's learned as well
over disappeared so now it's like a real
test to see if he's really definite to
the healthy lifestyle so pennant what
are you gonna do with the diet plan this
week it's two weeks biggest thing I
think is gonna put a new renewed focus
on getting sleep okay so they're not
getting enough sleep
no have you guys gotten enough sleep
that doesn't in a video description as
well but you've been struggling with
yeah so we're on five hours a night for
whatever reasons so what management
still a big problem yeah a concern so I
need to feed 60 hours plus into the
office that's a lot of work need to
spend that quality time with their kids
my family and yeah I need to spend some
good amount of time and legitimate
exercise in song and the diet plan diet
plan so four weeks left so the big thing
is you've got healthy you know that's a
big thing
we're not stuffing our faces with
mountains with chemicals and and other
people's ideas of what we should eat
because they want to make money when you
have some free time going do
a little bit of research on the food
industry and what you are actually
eating
all right surrender up did you go okay
so that's important thing eating healthy
but we're going to move a little bit out
of that helpful window outside okay so
we to do whatever you need to do style
feast it needs to be sustainable as well
hmm but so what we're going to charge
chimes to really learn some extra fat
which is not something you should really
do you should stay healthy you should
stay sustainable and consult your doctor
before you do anything that we say so
that least delay when something happens
so all right so what we've been doing is
been submitted awesome right hmm first
we started with just changing the food
in the kitchen we took up all unhealthy
stuff when we put in healthy food to
just kind of learn how to really start
this new healthy lifestyle then we
brought in another change and we started
that enzyme into fasting where I had a
new could eat for eight hours and then
16 hours and nothing then we changed it
a game to only eating four hours and 20
hours and not eating so happening what's
gonna happen with the diet plan for the
next two weeks yeah that was quite
really easiness I'm into that
and used to eating healthy realizing
that we don't need to eat as much so
that's a big thing we need to stay
healthy and we need to be able to
sustain whatever we'll be doing yeah
always going a little bit out of that
window off sustainable healthy living
and eating hmm we're going to delve into
more rapid fire and fat loss yeah
because we want to win this competition
we only have four weeks left so we're
really gonna push it yeah so first thing
we're gonna do is going to do a bit more
uh prolonged fasting okay so goal is
around five to three three to five days
okay so we'll see how it goes of course
we need to perform well at the office as
well so they can't let off on that yeah
can be sleeping on the job
yeah and it should be fine actually if
you do prolonged fasting if we're not
going to hit the gym as wide as we are
yeah
so with that and intimate fasting but
we're not just gonna have enough energy
because we can't let up on each other
and exercise yeah
but while we're gonna do this this
prolonged fasting we're gonna I'm just
going to use some supplements as well
that will help him and keeping the
energy that he needs as well but we've
been already changing your body a little
bit over time your buddy is getting used
to not eating that much food so it
already started to make that switch
instead of using sugar and all the bad
carbs and stuff using that for energy
his body are starting to use his own fat
for energy so it's burning that fat yep
so so we'll do the prolonged fasting
Lucy I guess if we do find that we can't
do a live office do when we need to
we'll probably cut it short by three
days probably
but I'm guessing in fact I should be
fine I think five days is bad with the
limit really we're really going to start
in the inspired I think it should work
well I think if we go seven days we
might be stretching it too much
especially because of the intensity
we're gonna put it in the jet just
before that we'll probably cut the carbs
out totally Oh mainly so we'll do some
green vegetables so I'm finished
broccoli and so on nice and will
increase our fat intake a little bit but
healthy fat yeah so from the fish
omega-3 fatty acids you can use some
nuts almonds walnuts those gonna stuff
yeah so that's the thing we're not just
going to grab a bucket of butter and
just either way on that fish is got a
lot of fat in it
almonds like you said I have always
great especially about the calorie
intake so fact is I think for like mine
Calabrese and calls is like four or
something so anyway get a lot more fat
in so make sure we get our protein in
yeah up to fact a bit healthy fats and
we'll really cut back on those cops or
no bread no starch is no potatoes things
like that and spinach because you need
to the first potassium potassium good
heart hero
so spinach we need the potassium
broccoli and things like that we need to
magnesium and so just to ease into that
before we go into that prolonged fasting
so that when we switch over to running
just on our body fat or what it isn't
going to go crazy and say what I'm gonna
get start eating a little bit of muscle
or start driving more proteins and stuff
and we need to make sure that we gel as
well it's every body part so that our
body recognizes that we use it and it
also doesn't start eating away at our
muscles yeah but after that period of
time it's important to start slow again
so we're not going to eat the fridge and
get out of it of what it's not going to
be ready for all of that and it's also
going to store a lot of that even now we
do do intermittent fasting and a small
period of time with lower insulin foods
and so let's go can see just cause chaos
and so first I just eat a little bit of
a before the first meal eat a little bit
more after that and so on every few
hours and the next day increase it a
little bit more and then after that
basically then the second week we're
going to be go back to intermittent
fasting again okay
so we'll probably do the four hours 20
hours again okay see how that works you
can also cut it back on dice that we
feel we're fine so we can then lighter
on the week might be going to one day
eat one day fast one day eat one day Fox
okay
so we'll probably do all today we'll do
the 24 and then the last part of the
week will probably would do one one eat
one that okay but everybody is different
right so you need to feel what your what
it tells you if you're starving you're
tired and you just can't do your work
and perform at the office or anything
like that
eat a bit more because your body needs
it right yeah yeah yeah okay and consult
your doctor before that yeah all right
so let's go to the workout routine
what's a specific changes do you want to
make yeah we've been getting in a good
exercise actually we've been really
hitting the gym hard yeah we're going to
make sure that's we well we try to go
even harder as long as we can make sure
we use every second mmm don't keep any
reps there's a 6-1 said that we're
skipping we're probably going to pay for
it later on so we're going to make sure
what we do everything as good as we can
and then we're really going to
concentrate on certain body parts what I
think I really need to fight this one is
basically my shoulders get them to look
a little bit better as much as I can
especially for the focus for a
competition yeah ABS I see because we're
really starting to do some of the belly
fat and so on
and the more we we lose the more we
should be able to see the have muscles
and things like that as well so but
we've got four weeks and we really need
to hit the gym hard and make sure we
don't skip on anything it's it's core
exercise hard as we can so in that 30
seconds or minute or whatever we're
doing the kind of exercise we're going
to go full out so with it if we're
really if we're in the in the high
intensity interval section if you do 30
seconds and you always can't breathe
that's good if you can do 35 seconds and
still feel fine then you've probably not
done it hard enough
yeah so really get that out we'll
probably even rest a little bit more if
we need so that we get our heart rate
back so make sure that we can get a full
out 30 seconds or a minute or whatever
it depends on what kind of heat we're
doing yeah so yeah so we are gonna focus
on all the body parts really good but
we're gonna push the ABS in this was a
little bit more
yeah so shall we take them to the gym
let's show them what we're gonna do
yeah let's go
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk home
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've been walking through the
to where
me astray yeah you follow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
before I guy said that's the work up and
see now you know the diet plan and
workout routine as well for the next two
weeks so let's fast forward let's go and
see how you did
let's see
[Music]
all right so I haven't made 82 kilos
it's not what we expected we expected to
do a little bit better but we know you
went through a few issues so what
happened this last two weeks yeah
yeah I too wanted to lose like I really
here into it was only four weeks left
now there's only two yeah but basically
a perfect story and I have that
motivation have that powers are going in
the fight you look all the way wrong
wrong so oh man
first thing at work basically I had to
change my schedule so after all
scheduled down and everything worked
perfectly but unfortunately we've
decided to change it price if you heard
Minear but I live actually a little bit
messed up my back somehow so and then
inflammation just kind of like took over
good in the cardio for by secure all two
weeks and like one during the night one
night woke up with just fine even where
so I had to take some pill to get that
inflammation down and things like that
sand yes terrible um birthday party you
ain't talking money as well yeah didn't
need that healthy there yeah so apart
from the cardio and the exercise I
didn't go too well
birthday party is people had a cake
there ice cream cake not one more to two
ice cream guys I think it was our
mistake was the MSR Nikita had a
birthday
[Music]
sorry about that but he also had a work
function study also yeah I wouldn't
function that to mean go eat a bit of
that little bit of this was just
everything but he lost two days got the
information down at least and we managed
to get a few kilograms off we actually
picked up some so what do we build about
two down towards the end at least at
least you you lost some sets again so
what is your goal for the next two weeks
because we only have two weeks left yes
oh so the main goal was to to lose more
than 20 guys yes that's the biggest one
then of course get flex and all the rest
so to do that we need to lose about
three four more yeah so the goal is but
the way we really wanted to be is about
five more so then entitled it looks
something like twenty two and so on yeah
so that would be great to me below
especially entry since I'm gonna eat
perfectly plain and also if the workout
will have to go really hard at it we're
gonna make it though are you gonna make
it yeah no we are gonna make it I think
we sorted all those issues and well
we'll have to really sit down and see
what we're gonna do
are we gonna make it are we not are we
gonna file but I think with good
planning mmm you and me together we just
need to implement it plan that and then
really get down girlfriend it do it yeah
I think it's possible we're really
really positive TD and how am I going to
do it put everything in yeah okay so how
does the tenant we're ready for this let
us know in the comments down below how
you did this last two which would love
to hear from you and don't miss next
week's video because it will be the end
let's see how much you lost let's here
we making or not see you guys in next
video Cheers
[Music]